it is an obsession isn't it this
obsession of unhappiness and there's a
historian Darrin McMahon who wrote a
wonderful book on the history of
happiness it's one of my favorite books
on happiness and recently he said you
know only in America can this an
obsession with them with happiness make
you unhappy and it's this you know you
have this feeling if there's perhaps
there's a little too much reflection on
happiness and I think there's a very
interesting philosophical point
alongside that comment which is does
this very willful strategic pursuit of
happiness bring you happiness and we
don't know the I think that the pursuit
of happiness is essential and vital to
our culture it's guaranteed in our
Constitution the right to the pursuit of
happiness and we know from 250 studies
in the social and biological sciences
that as you cultivate happiness you
become healthier you become a better
neighbor a better community member
you're more productive and creative at
work you're stronger and your family
with your friends it's a good thing to
go after and we're lucky that we can but
everything has its excesses and I think
there's a risk that it turns into
navel-gazing and the one thing that I
really felt in writing born to be good
is that we risk as our culture defining
happiness in terms of sensory pleasures
wow this is a delicious wine or in terms
of exercise or in terms of personal
gratification and that's a long-standing
tradition in Western thought that
happiness is economic gain and what I'm
trying to encourage is this more social
dimension to happiness where you bring
out the good in others
you